coronavirus pandemic has now claimed
more than 400
000 lives in the u.s they include
parents
friends students and essential workers
and the number of new cases
is still surging this morning we
continue to share the stories of the
remarkable
people we've lost here are just some of
the many
lives to remember
max osceola jr was a legendary leader
for the seminole tribe
of florida he helped facilitate the
seminoles
landmark purchase of the hard rock
international chain
in 2006 ensuring prosperity
for the once impoverished tribe our
ancestors
sold manhattan for trinkets today
with the acquisition of the hard rock
cafes we're going to buy manhattan back
one hamburger at a time
osceola was the second seminole to
graduate from college
and one of the tribe's longest serving
politicians
he started a program to make sure every
seminole
could go to college he always sacrificed
and gave to his community
said his son max osceola iii he was an
amazing
leader osceola and his wife marge
were married for 43 years and raised
four kids together he was such a
brilliant man
said marge he did what he was supposed
to do
in his lifetime max osceola jr
was 70.
aretha tilford was a mother and a
beloved attendance clerk at lincoln
performing arts elementary school
in louisville kentucky
miss aretha as the students called her
would greet everyone with
good morning sunshine aretha had a knack
for comforting children
and calming parents the families trusted
her said assistant principal michael ice
she would fix kids hair fix boo boos
just make them feel
whole again aretha owned a beauty
salon in town she loved gospel music
hallmark movies
and cooking family meals she was so
unselfish said mark tilford her husband
of 22 years
she just loved making people happy
she was my queen aretha tilford
was 56.
john elliott was a bar owner and a
stalwart of the denver music scene
as a kid john was an avid reader and a
precocious student
after college he joined teach for
america where he met the love of his
life
mary therese anstey they traveled the
world
living in scotland and australia before
settling in colorado
at his bar john championed up-and-coming
punk rock bands
he was known for his outspokenness and
his big
heart he was definitely a fierce friend
said rob rushing founder of
punkrocksaveslives.org
a non-profit john was involved in john
was battling pancreatic cancer
and thought he had coveted early last
year but when he caught the virus
a second time in november his body
gave out he was always about the grand
gesture
but he was also about the little things
said mary therese
that's something i'm going to miss john
elliott
was 51.
[Music]
brittany palomo was an emergency room
nurse
in south texas she was a bookworm who
could
light up the whole room with her smile
said her stepfather robert salinas
she was a fan of the chicago cubs and a
good brisket
brittany finished nursing school in
december of 2019
and started her first job as an
emergency room nurse
this past spring she loved it every day
selena said she gave it everything she
had
brittany had just moved into her first
apartment and bought a new car
in the fall when she tested positive for
the coronavirus
she died less than a week later and her
parents learned
she was pregnant brittany palomo
was 27. britney's family i know it's
just heartbreaking britney's family all
wore
chicago cubs journey jerseys to her
funeral as a tribute
i also want to say about aretha tilford
miss aretha she was called at school
the school has set up the aretha tilford
sunshine award
to honor her they'll give it to the
studio the student who embodies her
character
she liked hallmark movies i wrote it
down in fixing boo-boos yeah
this is why these stories are so
important that you tell anthony because
we just
throw out the numbers there are four
hundred thousand of these stories gail
all of those four hundred thousand
all those numbers have a name yeah four
hundred thousand and we could see
seventy five thousand more
by the middle of next month that's what
they're telling us that's right well
done